[Music]  if you are a product manager if you are  a product product owner if you are a new  x user experience designer if you are a  chief data officer or if you are a ceo  uh you have to wake up and to digitize  and to transform and the digital  transformation program is  a very useful tool to help you to do it  so my name is liliana i'm came from  paris france  and i actually working i'm working in  digital performance  in a tech banking company a large  corporation in france with  the digital transformation of stanford i  wanted to validate  that  that we are trying to operate is in a  good direction the digital  transformation program from stanford  helped me help me to  be more productive  productive and effective  with the cross-functional teams the roi  the return on investment is here and  it's positive